Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est la journée du Master Class'.
Ça va pas être un Master Class' trop long par rapport aux autres semaines
parce qu'il vient en complément d'un autre Master Class'.
Tout prend son sens maintenant !
Je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du palais mental.
Alors, pourquoi c'est en lien avec autre chose ?
Parce que le premier Master Class' que je vous ai fait
était basé sur la mémoire, sur la table de rappel :
les techniques de table de rappel.
C'était la vidéo 37 du 27 février. Je pense que depuis le 27 février,
vous avez eu le temps de travailler votre table de rappel
et donc qu'il est temps de parler du palais mental !
Le palais mental, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Excellente question ! Merci de l'avoir posée.
C'est un lieu imaginaire que vous allez créer dans votre tête
où vous allez pouvoir déposer des informations.
Et à chaque fois que vous allez retourner dans ce lieu,
les informations vont vous revenir à l'esprit,
telles que vous les aviez laissées au préalable.
Souvenez vous, je vous avais expliqué que le cerveau aime beaucoup les images, aime beaucoup l'imaginaire.
Et bien c'est pour ça que le palais mental marche bien.
Le premier palais mental qu'on peut se construire assez facilement,
c'est de prendre un lieu qu'on connaît déjà très bien, qu'on connaît par cœur.
Soit un lieu de notre enfance, soit un lieu actuel d'aujourd'hui.
Et c'est pas forcément un grand lieu, ça peut être une seule pièce.
Par exemple, mon premier palais mental, c'était ma chambre, où j'habitais chez mes parents.
J'imaginais faire le tour de ma chambre en point par point
de la porte où je faisais tout le tour de la chambre et je ressortais,
et ça me faisais un palais mental complet.
Car le palais mental doit toujours être associé à un trajet,
on y reviendra un tout petit peu plus tard dans la vidéo.
Choisissez donc un endroit que vous connaissez très bien, par cœur, en détails.
Un endroit réel donc, dont vous visualisez toutes les parties assez facilement.
Vous êtes pas obligés de le faire maintenant maintenant non plus, hein ?
C'est le principe du Master Class' :
vous pouvez le travailler après avoir vu la vidéo, dans la semaine.
Dans la vidéo numéro 34 je vous expliquais comment vous souvenir de n'importe quel numéro de téléphone.
Le palais mental permet ça aussi et permet encore plus si on l'associe à d'autres techniques.
Maintenant que vous avez un lieu en tête, vous allez devoir déterminer un trajet.
Et sur ce trajet on va identifier des "spots".
Les spots ça va être les endroits où vous allez pouvoir déposer mentalement quelque chose.
Je garde l'exemple de ma chambre.
Oui, ça c'est pas un bureau d'adolescent.
Enfin contrairement aux apparences parce qu'il a un drone et un truc... [rires]
J'ai oublié de grandir !
Vous pouvez identifier autant de spots que vous voulez :
5 c'est bien pour commencer, 10 ça commence à être un petit peu cool,
et après ça peut être 20, ça peut être 30,
ça peut être l'infini !
Donc dans ma chambre j'imagine un spot, ça va être au niveau de la porte.
Après il y avait une bibliothèque qu'il y avait sur ma gauche,
donc en passant le long de ce mur je vais m'imaginer la bibliothèque.
Et puis en face il y avait le bureau et la fenêtre.
Ça va me faire deux spots : le bureau et la fenêtre.
Et puis après je vais sur la droite il y avait des étagères.
Et puis encore sur la droite, il y avait un lit,
et puis à côté il y avait une autre armoire.
Vous un exemple de spots que je peux identifier.
Dans votre palais mental à vous, dans votre lieu,
vous identifiez des endroits où vous pouvez faire un trajet virtuel dans votre tête...
C'est Matrix, hein, là-dedans !
...où vous pourrez déposer vos informations mentales.
Pour vous servir ensuite de cet endroit magique et imaginaire,
vous avez deux techniques de dépôt :
le dépôt simple,
et le dépôt complexe.
Je vous confesse que je ne sais pas si ça se dit comme ça
ou si ça a été identifié comme ça, c'est mon jargon.
Le dépôt simple, ça consiste à mettre de vraies informations
qui existent réellement, sans les transformer, dans les zones de dépôt.
! EXEMPLE CONCRET !
Si je dois aller faire des courses et acheter une dizaine de choses,
et que je veux juste les mémoriser très rapidement sans aucun effort,
je vais me balader dans mon palais mental,
et à chacun de mes spots je vais mettre la chose que je dois acheter.
Il s'agit pas de mémoriser, il s'agit de créer un imaginaire concret.
Si je dois acheter un pack de lait, alors j'ouvre la porte de la chambre, dans le palais que j'ai pris en exemple,
et j'accroche une bouteille de lait à la poignée.
Quand je dis "je l'accroche", c'est vraiment dans ma tête,
j'imagine, à la poignée, qu'il y a une bouteille de lait, qui est accrochée.
Et puis je vais déposer dans l'armoire un autre objet,
à la fenêtre, sur le bureau, sur les étagères, sur le lit, encore sur l'autre armoire.
Je vais imaginer la présence de ces objets, dans ces spots là.
Donc c'est un dépôt simple, puisque
je prend une information qui existe, je prends l'imagerie d'un sac de tomates,
je dépose les tomates sur le lit.
J'ai un peu bugué, parce que je dépose pas vraiment les tomates sur le lit.
Je vais vous dire, je les éclate sur mon lit mental en fait ! Il est tout tâché de tomates
puisque plus l'information est riche comme ça, et un petit peu particulière,
mieux je vais la retenir.
Aucun autre effort de mémoire à faire, si ce n'est que quand j'irai dans le magasin,
je vais me rebalader dans mon palais mental, de spot en spot,
et les objets que j'y avais déposé vont me revenir à la mémoire immédiatement,
instantanément, c'est magique !
Mais qu'en est-il du dépôt complexe ?
! EXEMPLE CONCRET LA SUITE !
Je fais trop mal le super héros.
Le dépôt complexe c'est le fait de l'associer à une autre technique.
Et là ça devient très intéressant !
Si j'utilise la technique de la table de rappel,
qui me permet de coder des nombres en images.
Ça veut dire que je gagne en puissance dans ce que je vais pouvoir mettre dans mes zones de dépôt.
Je vais pouvoir déposer des choses qui sont abstraites comme les nombres et les chiffres.
Mon compte bancaire si je dois le connaître par cœur je vais le déposer dans mon palais mental.
Je vais le découper au préalable par nombre de deux,
je vais transformer chacun de ces nombres en images, via ma table de rappel
que je connais déjà par cœur puisque je la travaille depuis début février.
Et ce sont ces images là que je vais déposer dans les spots lors de mon trajet.
Ce qui fait que quand j'aurai besoin de mon numéro de compte,
j'irai dans ma tête, dans mon palais mental, je me déplacerai de spot en spot,
je verrai les images que je vais immédiatement retransformer en nombres et en chiffres
puisque je maîtrise ma table de rappel comme un réflexe automatique
et je serai capable de réciter mon numéro de compte, sans même avoir à chercher à le retenir concrètement.
De la même manière, vous pouvez imaginer des techniques
qui permettent de retenir des mots :
pour apprendre par exemple les verbes irréguliers en anglais,
pour apprendre les étapes clés d'un discours,
pour apprendre tout ce que vous voulez au final.
D'ailleurs dans l'une des vidéos de la semaine prochaine, je vous apprendrai
à retenir des mots dans une nouvelle langue
et vous pourrez vous servir du palais mental pour les ranger.
Les stocker.
Les stocker dans votre tête.
Si vous utilisez cette technique, évidemment
les numéros de téléphone deviennent très simples à retenir à la volée.
A la volée, ça veut dire qu'après il faut les mettre ailleurs pour décharger le palais mental.
Sinon la meilleure technique ça reste celle que je vous ai appris le 3 février pour les numéros de téléphone.
Enfin, technique que vous avez, j'espère, associé également à la table de rappel !
Vous êtes en train de devenir des bêtes de mémoire, là, les amis, hein !
Et enfin le palais imaginaire c'est un peu comme la table de rappel :
vous pouvez, vous devez, même, en créer plusieurs.
Commencez par un seul, évidemment, mais vous pouvez en créer des petits, des simples,
comme des pièces, comme ce que je vous disais.
Ou alors des trajets très simples comme le lever de mon lit jusqu'à la salle de bains,
donc là ça couvre plusieurs pièces, il y a pleins de zones de dépôt possibles.
Vous pouvez donc et devez donc en créer plusieurs.
Ça va vous servir dans certaines circonstances.
Il est intéressant par exemple d'avoir quelques pièces avec 5 zones de dépôt
pour pouvoir justement mettre des numéros de téléphone rapidement, à la volée
sans qu'on ai forcément le temps de construire tout l'imaginaire pour une histoire, comme dans la technique.
Vous pouvez évidemment avoir un palais imaginaire beaucoup plus complexe,
sur toute une maison par exemple.
Depuis toute à l'heure, je parle d'endroits fermés mais attention un palais mental
ça peut être aussi en extérieur, ça peut être sous l'eau, ça peut être dans les airs.
Et après pour les plus PSYCHO d'entre-vous,
vous pouvez créer voter palais imaginaire,
vous pouvez l'inventer de toutes pièces, le créer de toutes pièces.
Moi j'ai un palais imaginaire, il est assez peu fourni, en fait, en réalité.
Je vais vous le décrire, vous me prenez pas pour un fou.
Il y a un sas, on rentre, c'est une pièce toute blanche.
Il y a des fenêtres, mais depuis les fenêtres je peux voir ce que je veux, en fait,
ça dépend, c'est pas toujours le même paysage, c'est une autre technique que j'ai appliquée ici.
Et il y a beaucoup d'étagères et des grands casiers métalliques avec des tiroirs qui sont numérotés.
Dans ces tiroirs j'ai rangé des choses,
par exemple j'ai un casier métallique où je range tous les codes de portes d'endroits que je souhaite retenir.
Alors ça ça a un désavantage, c'est-à-dire que si je range pas dans le palais mental un code,
je peux le demander 20 fois à la personnes en allant 20 fois chez elle, en un mois.
Je le retiendrai pas.
J'ai tellement pris l'habitude de stocker les choses que si je le fais pas en fait,
je prête plus assez attention.
Vous pouvez donc essayer de construire votre propre palais,
ça vraiment je vous le recommande pour plus tard, dans le temps.
Ça se fait étape par étape, faut souvent s'y balader, même si on a rien a retenir,
pour un peu regarder ce qu'il y a,
et faire en sorte qu'il ne tombe jamais en ruines en fait, qu'il tombe dans les oubliettes de la mémoire.
C'est vachement beau ce que je dis aujourd'hui !
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à commenter,
à me dire quel palais vous allez prendre pour commencer ou si vous en avez déjà un, lequel c'est...
Quelle technique aussi vous utilisez...
On peut discuter dans les commentaires, ça c'est chouette !
N'oubliez pas de mettre un petit pouce en l'air sur le YouTube,
comme ça je le rangerai dans mon palais à moi, dans mon palais à pouces.
Partagez également la vidéo, ça peut intéresser des gens, ça peut les aider.
En tout cas je crois que ce savoir doit circuler.
Abonnez-vous, pourquoi vous n'êtes pas encore abonné ?
C'est pas la première vidéo que vous regardez, vous n'êtes pas encore abonné.
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne !
Voilà, là c'est en train d'apparaître, vous pouvez d'ailleurs aussi venir me voir en spectacle
aux Hallucinations Collectives.
Et rendez-vous demain matin à 11H pour une explication sur le Mental Vlog.
CIAO !